can be a little dangerous sometimes
the hard way okay I'm gonna pick it up
the hard way after attempting the
Footloose dance with her husband Kevin
Bacon in a now viral video yeah she did
great yeah Kevin posted uh the aftermath
snap which appeared as though Kira
injured her wrist in the process but
during the recent appearance on the
series xm's The Jess Gaggle show Kevin
Assured everyone she's healing just fine
take a look we'll see you tomorrow
do it one more time bye let it rip
there we go what I didn't realize I
realized this in retrospect that there's
actual tutorials to show you exactly how
to do this but I said to Kira honey can
we pull this off and she's like yeah
sure we could do that so the first
couple of practice rounds we did was on
the bed because if I dropped her she'd
have some you know a soft place to learn
yeah what's so funny about it well first
off her wrist is fine okay it wasn't it
wasn't such a big deal yeah no no no she
just no it was a little it was a little
um you know because she got a little
black and blue and and she was icing it
up a little after after we uh because it
took us several attempts you know to
pull that off